hi I'm Patti Kim today we're off to
Egypt sometimes called the world's
original tourist destination people from
all over the world come to this North
African country to walk in the land of
the Pharaohs and while most come to see
the pyramids there's a lot more here to
be discovered filled with ancient
temples and artwork outside the bustling
cities Egypt remains an amazing journey
back in time largely desert Egypt is
defined by water the Nile River runs the
length of the country and along its
shores Egypt's ancient inhabitants build
their cities and temples to the gods the
river flows north coming up from East
Africa at the border with Sudan past the
spectacular ruins of Abu Simbel and a
huge man-made lake nasser up through
loops or the country's ancient capital
and eventually through cairo before
splitting into a maze of tributaries and
emptying into the mediterranean sea
it's along this river where most
travelers arrive to in the bustling
modern capital Cairo is a sprawling city
of eight million and a sight unto itself
its streets teem with markets mosques
and museums at the Egyptian Museum over
120,000 artifacts are on display from
throughout Egypt storied history
including the famous golden death mask
of the Pharaoh Tutankhamun the citadel
of salad in an ancient fortress stands
guard over Kairos many mosques and
palaces all available to explore to see
the city from the water you can rent an
Egyptian sailboat called a palooka for a
leisurely glide down the Nile Cairo also
makes an excellent base for day trips to
to the historic sites just outside city
limits best known of course are the
Pyramids at Giza visitors arriving at
the site will find plenty of company as
many as 5,000 tourists see the pyramids
every day at Saqqara - or you can see
the earliest known pyramids both sites
are still near the Capitol but further
from the crowds going even further
afield a three hour train ride brings
you to Alexandria Egypt second largest
city once home to perhaps the greatest
library of the ancient world
Alexandria today has reconnected with
its lost past the bibliotheca
alexandrina is a modern day Research
Centre an architectural marvel
the city's sandy beaches and vacation
resorts make it an excellent place to
relax and unwind after the hustle and
bustle of Cairo after the pyramids
Egypt's greatest monuments are in the
south the town of Luxor lies next to the
ruins in the ancient Egyptian capital of
Thieves
on the east bank of the Nile are two
vast temple complexes Luxor and Karnak
they could be called the greatest
open-air museums in the world
here the Pharaohs of the Middle Kingdom
held ceremonies and celebrations from
the west bank of the Nile you can travel
to the valley of the kings where the
Pharaohs of the 18th 19th and 20th
dynasties were laid to rest its most
famous tomb belonged to the boy King
Tutankhamun
the hieroglyphics and reliefs in the
tombs chart the Pharaohs accomplishments
in life and the hopes in the afterlife
last on the tour of must-see attractions
of the temples of Abu Simbel they
located at Egypt's southern border the
town is easily accessible by boat along
Lake Nasser by bus or by air 65 foot
tall statues of Ramses the second guard
the entrance built as a testimony to his
empires wealth and power the site
continues to impress visitors today of
the grandeur of ancient
the best time to visit Egypt is in the
cool weather in springtime between March
and May light long-sleeved clothing is a
must
to protect you from the Sun and comply
with local sensibilities English is
widely spoken but learning a bit of
Arabic goes a long way to making your
trip one in a lifetime